Yo what it do?
This week we gettin EVEN with The Count of
Monte Cristo by Alexandre Dumas.
Edmond Dantes got it made.
1.
Soon
he gonna start runnin his own ship like a
boss, and 2. he bout to tie the knot with
his bangin hunny Mercedes.
But whenever a playa ballin relentless, you
can bet they gonna be a pack of haters tryna
trip up his game.
Danglars be jealous of his career blowin up,
Fernand eye-fu**in Mercedes’ sweet ass on
the reg, and Caderousse just hatin cuz haters
gonna hate.
So these three lil bitches write a
letter claimin Edmond a traitor, even though
our true blue sailor as straight as they come.
Even the law man Villefort takes a big ol’
dump on Edmond.
Since Villefort’s daddy an anti-royalists
snitch, he gotta make sure errybody think
he on the up and up.
So Edmund gets thrown in prison with no trial.
While he doin dat hard time, Edmond
meets a prisoner named Faria.
He learns Edmond real good and tells him that
there be a swoel fortune stashed away on the
island of Monte Cristo.
And when they scott free, dem playas gonna
be sittin FAT.
Thing is, old man Faria snuffs it before errythings
all kristal and benzes; so Edmond hides in
his body- bad, escapes dat trap, and flows
over to Monte Criso Island.
Time to make it rain, son!
Later, Edmond finds out that girl
Mercedes married Fernand after his disappearance.
SKANK!
With all dat fast money in tow, Edmond buys
himself a new name,
does a few good deeds on the DL, and vows
to use the rest of dat paper to fu** some
haters UP.
STREET JUSTICE!
First up in Caderrouse whose
dumbass tries to rob Monte Cristo.
sh** goes south when his greedy ass gets shanked.
One down.
Hater numba 2 is Fernand.
By
slangin dat cash, Da Count digs up enough
dirt to WRECK Fernand and his family.
Seems ol Ferny got hood rich by betraying
royalty and sellin two peeps in to slavery.
Along with all of high society, Mercedes and
his boy Albert chunk deuce to Daddy F and
and dat chump ices himself.
Another down..
Next on the sh**list is Villefort.
Word is that Villefort’s biddy got beef
with some of her family, so da Count MC teaches
her how to slay homies by slippin some poision
in they joose.
As she droppin em one by one, MC not only
gets this sucka called our in front of errybody,
but also gets him to convince his wife to
KILL HERSELF.
COLD BLOODED.
When Villefort drops from top dawg to bottom
bitch, fool loses his mind.
One to go.
They ain’t nothin Danglars love
more than his paper.
So that’s exactly what the Count fu**s with.
After jackin up his cashflow, the Count sicks
the mob on Danglars’s
ass and robs him of every single dime he got.
But it ain’t all dat ruthless,
couz.
Our boy helps out Maximillian, the son of
an old homie.
He be hollerin at Villefort’s daughter and
the count steps in to hook a brotha up.
After dat, the Count rides off in to the sunset
with a hunny named Haydee all up on his nuts.
What a motherfu**in pimp.
Peep this motif, blood.
This book
off da heezy with the number of storm and
dark cloud images bein slung up in hurr.
Like when Edmond finds out he bout to get
fu**ed by Villefort, before he meets Faria
up in the clink, right after Fernand gets
put in his place, I could go on playa!
After gettin wrecked by them three haters,
a storm be brewin in our boy’s soul.
And who can blame him?
Like a bolt
of lightning, Edmond’s righteous livin’
falls to sh** in a muthafu**in FLASH.
And Edmond ain’t the only one.
Check what Villefort say about his daddy.
Bad sh** can come at any time.
And
when it do, it don’t give no warning, it
just happens from one second to da next.
Matter of fact, my day one brutha
Herodotus layin dat same game in his Histories:
But happiness is too good for deez haterz.
A split-second of pain when dat hot lead goes
through their dome ain’t enough.
Edmond don’t wanna just ghost them fools-
he gotta make feel the pain he been feelin.
But you gotz to be careful when you
comin out dat hard.
After Edmond peeps Villefort’s wife and
son layin stiff, he start tweakin and realize
he mighta taken this whole revenge game a
little too far.
Cuz like Franz say;
Make sure yo drafts go down smooth
by hittin subscribe and checkin out my store.
Peace yall!